let's get into talking about computer
science terminology basically if you're
entering this field there are a few
words buzzwords or just regular
knowledge words that you need to know in
this industry some of them are very
basic and that's what this video is
going to cover a lot but I have a lot of
terminology that I want to discuss I
think it's only appropriate for the
first term to be computer science what
is computer science computer science is
a science that deals with theories and
methods and processing information on a
digital computer it is also the design
of computer hardware and software and
the applications of a computer or in
layman's terms is the study of the
principles and use of computers in order
to understand computer science you kind
of need to understand a computer and I
mean don't get me wrong
everybody knows what a computer is but a
good way to put it into words for us who
are entering in the field of computer
science and software engineering is that
a computer is a machine that performs
computations based on instructions
instructions that's an important word
the computer is made up of two
components hardware and software
hardware is the physical components of a
computer the best way that I learned
every little piece of computer is
building mine right there myself I think
I did that about four years ago and I
did all of the studying and all of the
work figuring out why I should get what
CPU for my usage graphics cards storage
memory cooling all of that stuff all
inside of a computer the best way for
you to learn it is actually putting
yourself in the shoes of somebody who
needs to build a computer because you'll
take everything into consideration
before dumping what a thousand fifteen
hundred dollars into a computer at least
I do I make sure I do all of the
research before I spend that much money
so that's a good way to learn the
hardware of computer software on the
other hand is not a physical component
it's basically a set of instructions for
the hardware you can think of these
instructions as files that are saved in
your computer because every time you
open something like Adobe Premiere
everything you do is sending
instructions back and forth between the
hardware the software or the
instructions aren't in English or any
other spoken language it is a
programming language the language that
is used for different types of software
varies but that's essentially how we are
able to set instructions for the
software to present and to do what we
need it to do or basically just to sum
all that up hardware some
that you can physically touch and
software is the instructions for the
hardware since we're on the topic of
software let's talk about program with a
lot of misconceptions a lot of different
words that really kind of mean the same
thing that is program is basically a
piece of software or you can think of it
as an application it is a file saved on
your computer written in a programming
language filled with instructions to
tell your hardware what to do in our
world we don't call instructions
instructions recall instructions code
code is a bunch of words and well well
basically this this is code and this is
written using a programming language so
you can think of code as the
instructions programming language is
what you write the instructions with and
everything combined is a software
application or program the first thing
they'll teach you in any computer
science degree is computer hardware
that's why I emphasize understanding all
the components within a computer because
you need to learn all of that before you
learn programming to be an efficient
programming and actually understanding
what you're doing so let's talk about
the six main components that make up a
computer's hardware we have the central
processing unit or the CPU we have the
main memory we have secondary storage we
have input/output devices we have the
network and we have the bus the CPU is
the brain of the computer it executes
instructions such as code in a program
the main memory also known as the random
access memory or you may know it as RAM
for short that's used to store the code
from your program and it stores the data
that your code is operating on while the
program is actively running for example
when you open an application such as
Adobe Premiere the code to run Adobe
Premiere loads into the main memory then
you have your secondary storage that
stores your program and data when it's
not in use and in order to do any of
this you need input/output devices a few
examples for input devices would be the
mouse the keyboard the microphone output
devices would be the monitor the
speakers or the printer which is Right
right there
the network essentially is what you
connect your computer to Wi-Fi internet
in order to communicate with computers
all around the world it allows you to
send and receive data from a computer
such as an email text message what have
you now the bus is a group of wires
inside this computer case right here
that connect all the hardware components
the main reason for that well it needs
to pass data from one piece to another
per hour
this example when you load up Adobe
Premiere you have your secondary storage
sending data to your main memory and
then what you save and shut down that
application it sends everything back to
the secondary stores to then be
retrieved once you open the application
back up and then back into the main
memory and then so on and so forth
and onto synonyms we kind of addressed
this previously when we're talking about
code and instructions or whatnot and a
lot of these groupings that we're going
to talk about here the groups of
synonyms can vary slightly depending on
how they're used but for just like a
basic level of knowledge this it's
essentially synonyms you have code which
are computer instructions you have
computer instructions which is software
you have software which is a program
also known as an app or application and
now although I consider code is which
you would open in a text editor you see
the entire programming language that
programming language is what you call
the code that would be the nitty-gritty
of an application and the application
would be essentially the packaged
product basically what the consumer
would see but you can see how they can
be used synonymously and then you'll
hear the terms like coding programming
software development software
engineering or coder programmer software
developer web developer a software
engineer you'll hear those types of
terms be interchanged a lot into
everyone on the outside world those mean
the same exact thing on the inside world
depending on what your company does and
what your called can mean different
things for example when you're called a
software engineer generally you work
with Java C++ enterprise level software
that type of stuff but then when you
move over to the people building
websites building web applications
building mobile applications and not
working with those particular languages
people like to call them software
developers but you can see how these
would be synonymous just know that when
someone talks about programming coding
software development that's essentially
all the same thing now we're getting a
little bit more complex starting off
with machine language versus programming
language in order to differentiate the
two you have to understand that
computers and humans understand
information in different formats
whenever you save data such as a word
document or a premier project the
computer stores that in a format that
will understand called binary or
otherwise known as machine language
binary is a language made up of
combinations of zeros and ones each
character that you'll see on your
keyboard numbers special characters
punctuation letters space
says tabs and and everything in between
has their own binary representation that
means a combination of zero and ones are
different for each and every character
and then there's something that I like
to describe in a way that it's between
binary in our human language and that is
ASCII code ASCII code is a numerical
code but instead of having zeros and
ones like binary or having the actual
number of the actual letter like English
that picks two numbers 0 through 9 for a
particular letter doesn't matter if it's
an A or B or C they're all going to be
different and they'll even be different
from uppercase to lowercase letters but
that format is also known to us as
decimal format and since that is base 10
as you can see because the two numbers
are chosen between 0 and 9 those are 10
numbers I'm sure you can guess binary is
base - that's because they choose only 0
or 1 in all honesty I'm not too sure how
well that came across to you so let's
try to consolidate our thoughts and
really drive this point home and I think
a real world example will do best so
let's say we're typing something in
Microsoft Word we type the letter A
we're going to keep it real simple we
type the letter capital A the numerical
value ASCII code of that is 65 I think
let me check yeah for capital A the
numerical code is 65 when you save that
data from your Word document into your
computer it saves the equivalent of 65
in binary for your computer so basically
you type in a capital A the numerical
code for that is 65 and then there's a
unique binary code that is the
equivalent of a C code the numerical
code 65 and the binary code the zeroes
and ones
is what is saved into your computer and
what your computer can read that's
machine language it's also referred to
as low-level language it's considered to
be low level because that's the language
that machines can understand and
programmers well programmers understand
programming languages also known as
high-level languages and just like in
English we have a set of rules to follow
and that is grammar everything that that
entails a programming language has its
own set of rules called syntax it also
has a set of defined words or key words
and these have a specific meaning within
that programming language and
unfortunately humans have no idea
to choose one language or another so
just like we have so many different
spoken languages we have also so many
different programming languages some are
better suited for web development and
even within web development there are
different languages to do exactly what
you need then they're different that
build mobile applications and then there
are different that build enterprise
applications and they're different that
build a hacking software machine
learning or what have you you you get
the gist but in addition to those
differences we also split our
programming languages into
classifications called programming
paradigms so if we look at the actual
word paradigm we see that that's a way
of thinking or way of doing something
essentially it's just a mindset a
programming paradigm is a way of
classifying something based on the
methodology of that programming language
a few of the common types of programming
paradigms are functional procedural
imperative in object-oriented as an
example we have two programming
languages Java and C however Java is an
object oriented programming language
while C is a procedural programming
language and for now we don't need to
know what it means to classify a
programming language as object-oriented
or procedural but it does help
understanding that there are different
classifications for different
programming languages now want to
understanding writing and saving code so
basically we've discussed this in part
one of computer science terminology
which is that programming essentially
means to write code that code is written
to create a program a program is
essentially an application an
application does something let's compare
this to something a little bit more
simple like an essay so when you write
an essay you open a piece of software an
application like Microsoft Word you
create a file in Microsoft Word you type
some stuff and then you save it as a
document or a PDF writing code is
essentially the same thing instead of
using Microsoft Word you'll use any type
of text editor whether that be notepad
notepad plus plus atom so but I can go
on and on about this or some type of IDE
and that is integrated development
environment IDE while a text editor is a
hammer in your tool belt an IDE is
essentially the tool belt that has all
of the tools with
that toolbelt so an IDE will have your
text editor a compiler a runtime
environment and a debugger so it has all
of the tools you need to create a proper
program and a debugger very helpful it's
a tool that programmers use to find
mistakes in their code and mistakes in
their code are called bugs hence
debugger bugs can appear at different
times within the development process
whether that be preventing your code
from compiling or preventing your
program your application from executing
or maybe your application is just doing
something incorrectly there are plenty
of jokes that hop around the software
development industry one of which being
something along the lines of you know I
spend 10% of my time writing code in 90%
of my time debugging debugging is a
skill that you will develop your whole
entire life after you create your
program you save your code within a file
this is also known as a source file so
instead of saving it as a document or a
PDF you save it as a source file this
basically shows you that your source
code is within this source file and just
as you would save a PDF as name dot
extension which is PDF you would also
save your source file as name dot
extension which your extension is
whatever your code is so dot Java is
Java dot CPP is C++ so on and so forth
now after you save everything in the
appropriate source files you want to run
your code to make sure that it works but
before you can run your code or
otherwise known as executing your code
you need to make sure that it compiles
you're essentially translate your source
file from high-level language to
low-level language in the form of an
executable so your computer knows what
you wrote because as we said before
computers don't understand high-level
language they only understand low-level
language so within that ID environment
you will use the compiler to compile
your code and that is a process of
translating from high-level language to
low-level language let me say that one
more time compiling is a process of
translating your high-level language
Java C++ Swift to low-level language
binary machine language and in that
compilation process it creates and saves
that translated code as an executable
file however if you have bugs in your
code that prevent you from compiling
that's when you need to activate the
debugger figure out how to fix your code
fix it until it is able to compile
otherwise it won't be able to create
that executable file and if it's not
able to create the executable file then
you're not able to run your application
and that is it hope you guys enjoyed it
if there's anything else that you want
me to discuss I'll be happy to just
leave them down in the comments below if
you liked the video be sure to like it
even if you dislike it feel free to
dislike the video twice and make sure
you subscribe especially if you did like
the video until next time guys have a
good one peace